ethan hawk says he's been preparing for
his latest role his
entire life he plays the fiery real-life
abolitionist john brown in the good lord
bird based on james mcbride's novel
it airs on showtime a division of viacom
cbs
hawk is also an executive producer
brown's story is told from the
perspective of an enslaved boy nicknamed
onion he's adopted by brown's crew of
abolitionist soldiers
as they fight to free slaves across the
state of kansas
in the 1850s
king of kings the man of the holy
trinity
and i hereby order
you to get
gifts in his holy name get
it's a little intense right ethan hawk
joins us first
on cbs this morning ethan first of all
it is just a fabulous performance
uh thank you for being with us welcome
uh i i think
some some thank you for having me yes
some people remember uh
john brown a little bit maybe from
history class i remember seeing
a picture of the of the huge mural of
him that's in the kansas state capitol
by jon stewart curry with his arms at
kimbo you know his hair looking like
it's almost on fire a tornado behind him
a bible in one hand and a gun in the
other who
is the real john brown
well that painting is really magnificent
and i had a poster of that painting in
my dressing room and stared at it every
day while i got dressed
you know who is john brown is a really
great question and there's
a reason why a lot of our history
teachers you know since the civil war
haven't taught us
it because he's an incendiary figure uh
in many many ways he started the civil
war and if you teach him
you have to teach young people uh the
history of slavery in this country and
that's something that
for a long time everybody's been really
uncomfortable with
i remember i my parents were split up
and my dad lived in texas and my mom
lived in vermont so i got two different
teachings about john brown i mean if his
name came up at all
one person would tell you it's the story
of northern aggression and you know
crazy
terrorist white guy and another side
would say he was a freedom fighter
and i studied his letters and in truth
he's an
extremely religious man who believed in
the unwavering equality of mankind who
was willing to do something about it
you you um you when you were when you
were reading
uh james mcbride's book which which is
surprisingly funny by the way as is
as is this series uh i mean you find
yourself laughing at things you would
never think you'd be laughing at
uh you you said you envisioned actually
jeff bridges playing
uh john brown
[Laughter]
well i don't know you know i think it's
a little bit
agree first of all you're so right
mcbride's book is hysterically funny and
the genius
magic trick that he pulls off and
telling onion's story
is he opens your heart by making you
laugh you know normally a lot of this
part of our history is just too painful
to look at but mcbride
puts so much love and humor in it and
you know i just love jeff bridges i just
pictured
a a hero he's always been a hero to me
and
but slowly i realized that um that
it was a really good part and why would
i give it up
you say you've been you've been working
your whole life ultimately to play this
part why
it just required it's a little bit like
king lear something you have to be
old enough to understand it and still
young enough
to be able to run around and have the
energy to to do all that i mean you know
that scene they just showed
i mean you know i'm carrying two pistols
i've got about
40 pounds of wool on me and it was 107
in virginia
and i got a scream all day it's about
the closest i ever came to having a
heart attack is in that shot
i can't imagine i mean there are a lot
of distinctive things about the films
one is your daughter maya is in this
is in this in this series yeah that's
the first time you've worked together
right
well i like to joke you know mine and
i've been working together since she's
about four i mean this
this young person is uh she's an
incredibly gifted kid and
uh she's not a kid anymore i shouldn't
say that she's she always has been
she plays music and she paints and she
takes right
she writes beautiful lyrics she has a
new album out
that's really pretty magnificent um and
she's on stranger things right now and
so
i i got really lucky because of her
success you know normally if a dad wants
his daughter to be in a show he's
producing everybody thinks it's nepotism
but when i said hey would maya be right
for this part
it was like uh that could could we get
in touch with her yeah
uh so we're very lucky to have her yeah
that's great like you she does many
things because i
i heard that during the pandemic in
addition to all the other things you do
write novels direct
act you've taken up painting
well i don't say i paint well let me be
clear
i've taken a painting to try to maintain
some
sanity uh you know i'm a very
busy restless person i i i work all the
time and
i don't think i realized how much of my
identity and
self respect and esteem i put into my
work
and without it i felt really off balance
yeah you know just not being able to go
to work every day
so i started doing uh you know i started
doing watercolors like
one a day just to try to remember every
day
yeah and whatever when i make myself
feel like i did something
i know the feeling well you've done a
lot ethan hawk the good lord byrd
is really fantastic premieres this
sunday on show time yeah
nice work yeah ethanol thanks so much
for being with us it's a really fabulous
performance congratulations